One of the natural response to what you
said,
would it be okay?
Well,
the,
the priorities are,
it's a rigged game because only when
there are the ones who are able to
procreate.
So what do we answer to that?
Of course,
it's a rigged game.
Obviously it's a rigged game.
Women have complicated lives and the
pill has made them more complicate.
Well,
that's not,
I wouldn't say that exactly because you
know,
a hundred years in 1895 the average
person in the western world lived on $1
a day in today's money.
Okay.
So those people worked so hard at,
slaved away to such a degree that you
can't even imagine it and all their kids
die.
Right?
So the death rate among kids below five
is beyond comprehension.
And so like women have terrible time of
timber.
Well,
so with men,
they got to be coal miners and soldiers.
Cause now that wasn't exactly
entertaining,
you know,
so life was very,
very,
very hard before we got rich and we're
rich.
Even those of you who are in this class,
you think you're poor.
It's like,
oh no,
you're not.
You're in the top one 10th of 1% by
historical standards and probably there
by her and world's standards as well.
Of course,
you could just compare yourself to the
few people to Richard than you and feel
sorry for yourself.
But that's a pretty pathetic in my
estimation.
So it's in,
it's certainly historically uninformed.
So yeah,
women have it rough obviously.
Now there's,
there's other things to consider.
You do live eight years longer,
so that's not trivial.
Testosterone kills men.
That's basically why men die earlier,
you know,
and men are much more likely to be
killed and dangerous jobs.
They do almost all the dangerous jobs.
They do almost all the outside work.
And there's lots of reasons that men get
paid more than women that have nothing
to do with prejudice.
It's because they take awful,
horrible jobs like working in the oil
rates in northern Alberta when it's
bloody 40 below and come out at,
you know of that after five years with
two or three fingers missing and,
and all warped up because you really
want to wrestle pipe when it's 40 below
and it's filthy with a bunch of ordinary
men who are hung over beyond belief.
It's like that's not very entertaining.
So yeah,
I mean each gender,
each sex has its own unfairness to deal
with.
But to think of that as a consequence of
the social structure,
it's like come on,
really.
What about nature itself?
And this is something,
this is something that seems to be
completely invisible on the left side of
the political spectrum.
So like of course you're a bloody
oppressed and your life is full of
suffering obviously.
But to think about that as a direct
consequence of unjust social structures
is just moronic.
It's like that's part of the reason,
a small part.
But look where you're sitting people,
it's pretty warm in here and you're so
privileged.
You could come here and Saturday morning
and listen to an intellectual lecture.
It's like you should be happy about that
because by historical standards,
you should be out lifting rocks in your
skeletal form about five foot three with
no teeth.
So have cougars,
cougars alliance.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
there's no gratitude.
That's the thing.
There's no gratitude for what our
society is capable of doing.